alors c'est pas de l'automobile c'est
une trottinette dont on parle maintenant
alors un peu d'ordre peut-être dans
l'anarchie tous ceux qui ont vu débouler
une trottinette au coin d'une rue ou
être frôlé par un engin qu'il arrivait à
pleine vitesse dans le dos au surf de
quoi on parle en tout cas la mairie de
paris la maire de paris annoncé cet
après midi que on allait interdire le
stationnement sur les trottoirs et elle
demande le bridage des moteurs
on écoute anne hidalgo sur la vitesse
qui est un véritable problème
je demande aux opérateurs de tout les
trottinettes électriques qu'ils brident
à 20 km/heure dans tout paris et à 8 km
heure dans les aires piétonnes les airs
de rencontre les zones les déserts les
plus central que c'est trottinette soit
[ __ ] alors qu'aujourd'hui elles sont
sur 25 km heure alors soyons clairs tout
de suite qui fait de la trottinette
électrique autour de cette table at-elle
dit alors qu'ils vous aurez parmi les
durs oui on va y venir sur le juridique
mais déjà sur les mesures bon là le tout
un chacun le usagers du trottoir
parisien nous avait toujours quelque
chose qui m'étonne aujourd'hui dans la
puissance publique c'est comme si elle
avait honte d'être une puissance et
dettes publiques
elle demande gentiment non elle et c'est
la mère de parisella régulatrice de
notamment de la circulation est là
devraient pouvoir les pouvoirs du maire
sont réels et existe un moment donné on
impose justement est-ce que c'est pas là
où le bât blesse parce que la mairie
parée à l'essai effectivement
s'installer tout c
ces opérateurs de trouver aucune règle
au départ et puis maintenant mais en
fait on a vu qu'à nantes je me suis
l'histoire la maire de nantes est un
opérateur de trottinettes qui arrivent
et qui a mis ses trottinette dans la rue
eh ben la mairie de nantes a fait
enlever toutes les trottinettes en
disant ce sont des objets abandonnés sur
la voie publique forcément le prochain
qui a dû arriver va d'abord négocié avec
la mairie avant de jouer à ça parce que
ça a un coût réel donc la première chose
c'est que de temps en temps on peut
aussi faire usage de ses pouvoirs
après en soit la trottinette c'est
plutôt un bon moyen de transport
pourquoi pas c'est plutôt écologique on
voit qu'on est sûr d'y arriver à
démontrer
on a quelques soucis mais il ya au delà
de la régulation de la ja dire de la
circulation est aussi la question de la
façon dont les gens travaillent on a vu
on a attrapé des genres rechargeant au
diesel des trottinettes électriques à
l'intérieur de véhicules quand vous dans
des conditions assez abominable gagnante
là pour le coup le bénéfice écologique
on l'a pas donc je crois qu'il faut
prendre en compte ces nouvelles formes
de mobilité et le faire comme on l'a
toujours fait en régulant en étant
exigeant et en passant de vrais accords
avec ces opérateurs et en chassant les
gens qui viennent prendre possession de
l'espace public un petit peu comme des
voyous de cette façon là ça ne se fait
pas il ya des lois on dépose pas son
matériel comme ça dans la rue bertrand
père il aurait fallu poser des règles
avant effectivement oui évidemment il ya
une façon alors d'abord politiquement et
sa lave plus vert que vert 1 maintenant
à paris il va falloir montrer que l'on
n'est plus écologiste que j et il ya
aussi une autre façon pour anne hidalgo
de se refaire une virginité après les
fiascos vélib
après les fiascos autolib avec les
contrats qui ont été ce mauvais goût
enfin tout ça a été quand même très
compliqué et puis on a une occasion
enfin après les voitures après et les
vélos d'avoir la trottinette comme une
sorte de voilà ça y est maintenant on
est au point et donc on va pouvoir
réglementer les réguler ce nouveau point
de revin sauf que il ya une chose
particulière c'est que autant pour les
vélib et laisse d'olive y avait des
emplacements donc il fallait
effectivement avoir contracté avec la
ville et donc il y avait un opérateur
tandis que la et une trottinette tout le
monde peut en mettre n'importe où et
donc d'aider les opérateurs y en a au
moins 10
ferhat heures moi je connais pas les
antécédents du dossier mais ils sont
arrivés ils ont posé leurs trottinettes
comme ça ça demandait rien à personne
les douze ils sont douze à paris mais
ils sont deux ils sont douze à paris et
d'ailleurs c'est que c'est un point
c'est intéressant que vous soulevez
c'est à dire que malgré les problèmes de
sécurité parce qu'évidemment il ya eu
des accidents dont on a entendu tous les
a aussi il ya un vide juridique
il ya eu ces questions réglementaires
qui allait forcément arriver et pour
être pour autant les opérateurs sont de
plus en plus nombreux et vous
12 à paris huit à lyon
il continua il continue à se développer
et pourtant il perd de l'argent parce
que les revenus générés par la location
ne couvre pas l'entretien et l'achat et
l'achat du matériel est il trop et
toutes les start up et des très gros il
ya des startups les starters trouve des
investisseurs quand même pour les
finances et parce que les investisseurs
se disent finalement au bout d'un moment
il y en aura il y en a un il ya un deux
ou trois qui finira par rattraper le
marché et qui deviendra qui deviendra
rentable
votre question au début je ne sais plus
mais le fait est qu'aujourd'hui il ne
devrait plus y en a de plus en plus des
opérateurs malgré pour les problèmes et
entendre un de ces le directeur général
de lyme c'est donc le plus gros je crois
à paris même en france
il s'appelle arthur louis jacques et
vous allez voir ce matin sur rtl il
jouait aux bons élèves
aujourd'hui il faut des règles nous
notre volonté est là sur le long terme
et sans règle ça peut pas fonctionner en
harmonie avec l'ensemble usagers la
route à travers un gros travail de
déplacement de je te demande des
trottoirs sur les zones de parking
autorisé alors ça prend du temps ce que
c'est très manuelle on devra avoir
terminé dans les tout prochains jours
si l'utilisateur ne prennent pas les
bonnes habitudes on peut accompagner les
bonnes habitudes en freinant la vitesse
vous accompagne pas on le fait déjà dans
certaines îles c'est très très très
malin comme stratégie va se conformer
qu'on est modeste on est on est bons
élèves c'est exactement mais je pense
aussi parce qu'à la fin on n'a pas les
cette extrême et il disait que
l'entreprise était si non rentables met
en scène allez le devenir mais de toute
façon s'il est le premier à pouvoir
prendre en charge et en plus il est
intelligent il se met même dans la
négociation de la réglementation s'il
est le premier à pouvoir s'adapter à une
règlementation oui à ce moment là il a
devant lui un boulevard
quelques mots sur le côté les accidents
les blessés on sait par contre qui se
retourner mais alors le l'opérateur depa
n'a pas de n'assure pas les utilisateurs
à six reprises cette acquisition s'est
gâté médiateur mais il ya un très gros
problème c'est à dire l'applicabilité de
la loi dite badinter à quel aviez loi 85
qui régit les arrêts les véhicules
terrestres à moteur est ce que c'est un
véhicule terrestre à moteur c'est pas
avec la fin là c'est et jusqu'à quelle
vitesse est ce qu'on va pour rentrer
dans le champ d'application de cette loi
est ce que c'est un vélo non c'est pas à
vélo parce que précisément il ya un
moteur donc il va falloir réglementé
probablement de façon spécifique les
trottinettes c'est ça qui est
merveilleux avec le droit c'est que ça a
évolué avec la modernité on vous écoute
on va lui demander pourquoi le fait que
ces trottinette quelque chose qui me
déplaît fondamentalement match pad mais
en fait on y réfléchissant je me disais
mais pourquoi au fond c'est pas plus mal
qu'autre chose enfin c'est
son temps et un justement durant leurs
échanges
je crois que j'ai compris ce qui me
déplaisait ton que ça c'est que c'est
encore une fois la marchandisation d'un
nouvel espace de l'existence parce que
c'est quand même un service c'est pas un
service gratuit envoyer des marchés etc
on vit dans une ville qui a une vie très
petite à paris moi ils trouvent que je
vais tous les déplacements quasiment à
pied dans paris et c'est une ville où
très facile de déplacer le déplacement
dans paris et un déplacement qui se
faisait essentiellement soit par an mais
trop bon payer un petit truc ou bien
tout simplement à pied à pied c'est
quand vous marchez c'est gratuit et
voulait dire que les trottinettes
réduisent l'espace gratuit
noémie que ça introduit dans un nouvel
état d'un nouvel événement de
l'existence de la quotidienneté dire
tout simplement fait de se déplacer on a
de nouveau un service payant alors vous
êtes si elles sont obligées de nom mais
c'est un service payant des impôts pour
rebondir sur je suis d'accord c'est que
pour une fois et de façon officielle les
trottoirs sont encombrés
alors qu'avant c'était sur la voie
publique sert la chaussée savent y avait
des stands de vélos des stands de
voitures mais là tout ça et de surcroît
en plus d'une fois sur deux ou même
beaucoup plus cassé brisé jonche le sol
tout ça n'est pas ça donne une
impression un peu nouveau monde a pas
fais toi même service est impeccable et
encore toi personne n'oblige pas les
formes sanctionnerait pas ce qui me
choque c'est vraiment le connaissez
elles marchent au pas et s'ils voulaient
un une un épisode de l'existence aussi
importante que celle de marc et moi je
sens que l'occupation de l'espace public
est vraiment gênant parce que c'est une
forme de préemption qui leur rapporte
alors que c'est pas du tout comme ça que
ça allait fonctionner et la deuxième
chose extrêmement paradoxal c'est qu'on
a énormément de problèmes
justement de surpoids qu'on incite de
plus en plus les gens à marcher qu'on
leur offre des montres qui compte le
nombre de leurs pas de même au téléphone
voilà concerne il semblerait qu'on soit
déjà extrêmement sédentaire
rappelons quand même aux gens que la
marche à pied il ya rien de mieux et
pour la santé juste bassement terre à
terre ça se termine quand même on l'a
déjà cités un par cette maman avec son
nouveau né
et puis par la pianiste de l'opéra de
paris qui s'est fracturé la main qui ne
pourra plus jamais jouer alors il paraît
que c'est un peu plus compliqué ça alors
c'est peut-être compliqué ça et voilà
et nos attaquants distille alors ils
sont en bas ils sont plutôt oui
comme vous a trouvé ne sont pas séduits
par les trottine atteint 71% d'entre
vous dise non pas du tout séduit pp anne
hidalgo seraient bien inspirés
d'interdire la circulation sans casque
de prévoir des hors droits de
stationnement adaptées d'autoriser leur
circulation sur toutes les pistes
cyclables
alors la circulation sans casque si j'ai
bien compris c'est parce que mettre un
casque un site alors il y avait une
explication parce que sinon ça paraît
aberrant comme ça mais c'est qu'il ya
une explication logique derrière que je
vais retrouver babineau la vitesse c'est
la vitesse qui pose principalement
problème on ne peut pas interdire la
trottinette c'est un effet de mode donc
nicole personnellement je n'habite pas
en ville et dans le moyen pays fait de
petites montagnes on n'est pas prêts
d'en voir ça c'est encore que on va
peut-être trouvé des anges louer des
vélos électriques
ah oui ça beaucoup de succès y compris
dans les liens peu plus montagne aussi
une trottinette se retrouvent sur le
trottoir sans utilisateurs on verbalise
qui questions réponses et r34 s'ils
doivent stationner sur les emplacements
de voitures ou attachement t-il les
trottinettes et payeront t-il le
stationnement
eh bien voyez plein de questions sur ce
sur ces engins qui effectivement
envahissent un peu notre espace